All we have to do now is explicitly write down the solution for the values of x
that satisfy this inequality. First, I'd like you to write the solution using
inequalities to show the ranges of x and then, I'd like you to write it in
interval notation. Be really careful about where on a number line these
intervals fall, and think back to what we learned about compound inequalities.
These use either, or, in-between two inequalities or and, where things with and
can be written using the change notation, or something similar to this. Remember
also how compound inequalities translate into interval notation. If you need to
review any of this, you can always go back to a previous lesson to look it up
and refresh your memory. Or you can go to the forums, they're always there to
help you.